let's consider the following problem
suppose we have an inclined plane and on
this inclined plane we have a block and
down here at the bottom of the inclined
plane there's a little bumper it can be
a spring of some type and what we have
is the block is sliding down the
inclined plane bouncing off the bumper
and sliding up the inclined plane and
what we'd like to do is find the
acceleration of the block for both cases
so when it's sliding down let's do an
analysis on that motion well the first
thing we have to do is again identify
our system in this case just the block
will be our system so we'll put in the
block as our system and now we have to
analyze the forces on the block as its
sliding down there is a friction with
the coefficient UK and so we have the
gravitational force mg we have a normal
force of the surface on the block
pointing up and because the block is
sliding down remember that our friction
force is opposing that motion now when
you have a free boundary force diagram
we have to decide which way should we
how should we choose our coordinate
systems what we want to encourage you is
not to choose a coordinate system unit
vectors horizontal and vertical just
because that's the way one always does
it but to use the constraint of the
system to help you choose the coordinate
system now a technique for doing that is
to draw the what you think will be the
acceleration on your sketch so I expect
that a is going to go down the inclined
plane that's taking to account that
there's no motion perpendicular to the
inclined plane this drawing the
acceleration remember acceleration is
not a force but this gives me a clue for
how I should choose my unit vectors I'll
choose them so that I hat points down
and so I essentially have a 1/2
mental motion and I'll choose J hat
pointing out now I'll introduce an
angle-theta
that's the same angle theta here and one
has to be a little bit careful in doing
these types of sketches but this is also
the angle theta and now I've chosen a
coordinate system unit vectors I've
indicated relevant angles and the rest
of the problem is just vector
decomposition in applying Newton's
second law so we'll write down F equals
MA and I'm going to indicate a d4 we're
talking about the acceleration downwards
and we have two directions to analyze
the eye hat and the J hat directions so
in the direction tangent to the surface
we have a gravitational force downward
mg sine theta we have the kinetic
friction force opposing that motion and
that's equal to M a D where ad is the X
component of the acceleration in the
vertical direction we have the normal
force minus mg cosine theta and here's
where our choice of coordinate system
helps us the constraint of the system is
that a Y is zero when we choose Y to be
the perpendicular direction so this side
is zero now I look at this
and I see a F and N and that's only two
equations and three unknowns but now I
have a force law for my friction which
is that the kinetic friction is equal to
a coefficient UK n and I can see from
this equation that's mu K mg cosine
theta and now I'm in position in which
to substitute my friction into this
equation and solve for the acceleration
notice the mass will cancel and what I
get is that the acceleration going down
is just equal to G times sine theta
minus mu K cosine of
and so that's how we can analyze the
acceleration when the block is sliding
down next we want to analyze the
acceleration when the block is going up
now when you have a case like that it's
sometimes easier again just to draw will
still choose and now the interesting
thing is which ways acceleration
pointing just because the block is going
up the acceleration is still pointing
down how do you know that well we'll see
that when we analyze the forces so we
still have n we have mg but now the
crucial point is this is going up the
crucial point here is that the kinetic
friction is always opposing the motion
so when the block is sliding up the
kinetic friction is down and all that we
have is a sign change here this is now
plus if I choose my I hat and J hat in
the same direction notice both of these
forces have a positive component in the
I hat direction so the acceleration will
be down and rather than do all the
algebra all I'm doing is changing the
sign and I get that a up is equal to G
sine theta plus mu K cosine theta and
although it may seem slightly
counterintuitive that the acceleration
as the block is going up in magnitude is
bigger than the acceleration as the
block is going down and that's because
of the direction of the kinetic friction
force